here now with the very latest on the
ground in
israel at the israel gaza border is our
own
trey yanks trey
sean good evening a massive escalation
tonight by the factions inside
gaza who fired dozens of rockets towards
israel's second largest city
tel aviv just before we came on with you
here sean there were more rockets fired
from the gaza strip and we
saw different barrages from different
areas of
gaza israel's missile defense system the
iron dome was able to intercept
a number of these rockets that were
fired but unfortunately according to
israeli media there has been
another fatality they are looking into
other injuries after
certain rockets impacted areas in
central israel
this all comes amid a day of fighting
the past 24 hours
we've seen more than 500 rockets fired
from gaza
into southern and central israel it all
started yesterday around 6 pm when hamas
the group in control of gaza
threatened to fire rockets towards
jerusalem they
kept their promise and did just that
israel has been responding across the
gaza strip with air strikes and drone
strikes
we do know inside gaza according to the
palestinian health ministry at least 30
people are dead
some of them children on the gazan side
we
also know that islamic jihad has lost at
least three rocket commanders
from targeted strikes by the israelis
and a 13-story building
also destroyed as the factions there say
if any more towers are hit
they will fire more rockets towards tel
aviv israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu says that he will use
all the force that he can to restore
security to the area
one area of note and off in the distance
now we can hear explosions inside
gaza those are fighter jets targeting
more positions
in response to that rocket fire that
just happened a few moments ago
sean all right trey great reporting by
the way stay safe
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else